Beatrice is ordering
pizzas for a party.
Each pizza is cut
into 12 pieces.
Beatrice wants to
have enough pizza
so that each person
can have 4 pieces.
And 16 people will
be at the party.
A lot of information
in this problem.
If Beatrice buys 7 pizzas, how
many extra pieces will there
be after each person
eats 4 pieces?
So to do this, let's think
about how many total pieces
she will have.
And then let's think about
how many total pieces will
be eaten by the 16 people.
And then we'll figure how
much that she had extra.
So first, let's think about
how many total pieces.
And I encourage you to pause the
video and try to figure it out
yourself.
She ordered 7 pizzas.
How many total pieces
are there going to be?
Well, you have 7 pizzas.
7-- that's the number of pizzas.
And if you have 12
pieces per pizza,
you multiply by 12 to get
the total number of pieces.
So this is number
of pieces per pizza.
And 7 times 12 is equal
to 84 total pieces.
So that's how many
pieces she's got.
Now let's think about how many
get eaten by the 16 people.
So you have 16 people.
16-- that's the
number of people.
And this little symbol,
that's shorthand for number.
16 people, and they
each eat 4 pieces.
So 16 people times
4 pieces per person.
So number of pieces per person.
16 times 4 is 64.
So that's 64--
not 84-- 64 pieces
are eaten by the 16 people.
So how much does
she have left over?
Well, if you start with 84
pieces and 64 get eaten,
84 minus 64 is 20.
We deserve a drum roll now.
You have 20 extra pieces after
everyone eats their share.